karen it's good to see you again you
were
so good in this thanks keisha how are
you
[Laughter]
i am good i have to ask you what was it
about this series and this true story
that made you want to get involved as an
ep
as an ep i think if i'm completely
honest i mean
great great acting opportunity as an
executive producer if i'm being really
honest i just thought wow this is going
to be good it would be really good if i
was a producer on this
that was kind of that was kind of it you
know
i i had wanted
to i'd have had a long standing
developing interest in in maybe having a
hand in the producing of things that i'm
involved with yeah um
but i suppose when this turned up and i
just fell in love with it in the way
that i did i was greedy you know and i
tried my luck with being a producer as
well as an actor and dennis and the
other producers were very kind and
thought oh come on let's give him a
let's give him a shot and shut him up
and they let me do it and it wasn't a
disaster so
no it wasn't a disaster i'm not sure if
you've heard or seen but fans really
want you to play hercules in the live
action remake right
would you do it
hey i mean
uh
look i love that movie so you know um
and
i i i'd be i'd be open to it i think
yeah of course he doesn't have many
songs though does he i don't think
and he's only got one song so i thought
you'd find it difficult being in the
middle of loads of people singing
amazing music and me not doing much
singing and just we're lifting weights
well maybe you could produce it and then
and put loads of songs in for myself
let's do that keisha you're a genius
um what was it like just getting into
this mindset of your character jimmy for
this what did you have to do
um
well listen to paul really you know it's
um it's dark stuff and
um it's not it's not it's not always fun
material you know and i know it really
took a toll on paul bless him because
it's it's just not nice to it's not nice
they're not things we want to talk about
let alone pretend that you know talk
about them at that that that proximity
um
so really but you know it's such great
writing and dennis has kind of done all
the work for you in terms of
imagining the horrors um so really all
you have to do is is show up and and be
present um
and i
i
you know
the the i was both captivated and
horrified by the writing and yeah um
and so
i was really just very very excited to
be there and be a part of it
remembering the late great
ray liotta um do you have a great memory
from working with him i only have great
memories of working with him um it was a
it was a very it was you know ray
because he's really he's ray liotta um
he
was only with us for a few weeks so that
you know they they had condensed
the the character of big jim in the
schedule
so that it was an appealing prospect for
an actor of his caliber and we were
lucky enough to get him but but that
short time frame we spent together was
very very very special for me the first
day you know i met him
i stepped on set and he was kind of in
his own world doing his own thing
and i didn't know how to you know
to sort of bridge the gap as it were and
he saw me and he just got up and walked
up to me and he just he just he just
hugged me and held me
and um
and he didn't really say anything else
you know
he didn't really say anything else and i
think it was just
he just wanted to create some tenderness
between us before we did what we had to
do and it it really worked you know i
fell in love with him immediately
and um
and actually the scenes are
some of
you know
am i
actually i think you know what i
actually think the scenes with ray are
my favorite
bits of acting i've done probably wow
yeah i think i think so yeah they were
special for me for sure
you